In Ukraine, parliament observes a moment of silence for victims of a methane blast...
...at a coal mine in the rebel-held region of eastern Ukraine.
30 people are dead and dozens are missing.
In Indonesia, two convicted Australian drug smugglers are transported to an island,...
...where they and other foreigners face execution.
In Egypt, at least 16 people were injured in a fire...
...at a convention hall in northeastern Cairo.
In Mexico, the government applauds capture of one of the country's most wanted drug lords,...
...Servando "La Tuta" Gomez in Michoacan.
And finally from India, thousands of Hindu pilgrims and tourists...
...participate in the celebration of Holi, also known as the Festival of Colors.